well let's jump to the story we have
from timcast.com
more than one million voters one million
leave democrats and switch to gop
democrats urge biden to change course to
avoid being demolished in the midterms
okay
with 134 days into the midterm elections
no outcome is guaranteed but the new
data is a fresh warning to democrats now
many people are arguing
that this is democrats joining the gop
to sabotage the primaries perhaps
i think that's probably a tiny fraction
of it i think people don't don't think
like that the average person wakes up
they go to their job at the bodega or at
the mall or the restaurant or they're a
carpenter or a tradesman and they're not
sitting there thinking like how can i
sabotage the rival political party
they're just like why is my gas so
expensive
i'm voting republican this time and
that's it
what do you think why do you think
people are quitting the party i think
well
i think we're you know driving up here i
was thinking about yonkin and what
happened with him uh in virginia and i
think people that that vote transcended
politics i think parents through covert
had seen for the first time the
education system the disarray of that
the introduction of crt to young kids
and um you know sex ed to six seven
eight-year-olds and they were just done
but just done and their values uh just
had it so i think um you know you can
only drink so much woca cola
before before you get you know you just
passed it and over it i mean i was woke
about seven years ago and you have to
break through beyond that pre-existing
belief system and you do when you
finally see enough of it you go this is
nonsense this i'm being fed propaganda
not news
and and this
ideological extremism post-modern
progressive whatever you want to call it
this intersectionality is so out there
that you know i said before you know i
didn't leave the left the left left me
and where did it leave me in in kind of
limbo going well am i because i can
remain we don't have to affiliate we
don't have to i'm not a registered
anything in england but in america it's
you know obviously a very different uh
system and i just think um people have
had it
they've just had enough you know what no
no no please i was gonna say it's funny
that you know elon musk posts that meme
of the left moving further and further
left and that was colin wright's name by
the way right exactly exactly
i've said this
you've said it
elon musk is saying it i just don't
understand at what point will the
democrats will the liberals on the left
realize there is a recurring pattern
here where a whole bunch of people are
like the left is leaving me behind and
they're like so what
okay sheamus is exactly where he's
always been as a conservative pretty
much i've moved a bit over the years on
different things i've actually probably
yeah yeah i mean i used to be more
libertarian but yeah pretty much the
point is socially for sure if with that
colin wright meme posted by elon
if we
as like former left liberals
are now
being left behind
politically we are closer to
conservatives than the modern left
what do they think is going to happen in
terms of the vote they'll cease to exist
they're they're lopping themselves off
from political discourse i think what
they what we're seeing here and it's
interesting that you mentioned junkin
and those parents because i think what
they've done possibly without realizing
it or maybe without caring about it is
they've turned parents
writ large they've turned parents into a
voting block and i don't think they've
realized how unbelievably damaging this
is going to be that's insane because
they have they've done it and they've
turned them all against them and they've
told them you're terrorists go away we
don't want to hear what you have to say
we have your kids now we see as well i
think from the alphabet you know the
identity politics eventually devours
itself and that's what we're seeing with
the lgbtq you know it goes on and on and
on and they're fighting amongst
themselves and and it's that you know i
don't know the liberal elites though
they're just going to keep
you know living in their ivory towers
and making money and pretending and
purporting to be fighting for
you know the working man and
dis-impoverished neighborhoods and when
really that it's quite the opposite
that's going on that's what i see we
live in the upside downs with a lot of
hip-hop moral hypocrisy seems to be rife
at the moment there's a
bill crystal right he's a neocon
and he tweeted out something about how
the supreme court is extreme or
radicalized for overturning roe v wade
when he actually wrote something like 25
years ago an article saying row must go
so how is it that the neocons of of
eight years ago all of a sudden are just
agreeing with democrats here's an
example the lincoln project we are going
to restore the party of lincoln from you
know after donald trump donald trump
loses and they go
we're
we're basically democrats we're just
here to rag in republicans come on so
these people who claim to be republicans
claim to support these values
are now all of a sudden supporting
democratic policy and values like
jennifer rubin's a great example
conservative writer and often she's like
yay stacy abrams yay democrats and it's
like do you have principles or are you
just drifting realistically democrat and
republican are just jackets uh anyone
just because you're wearing a coat with
a name on it a word on it doesn't mean
that it's gonna make you think a
different way it doesn't matter what you
call yourself but they do are those
people they are thinking a different way
bill crystal was always looking for i
mean he was a proponent of the war in
iraq he loved the invasion and conquest
now democrats have a uh
they have a higher approval rating for
george w bush than than republicans do
for some reason
but you have uh
my point is
these people are exposing themselves as
never having actually believed in
anything
like row is bad it's like bro you wrote
the article on why row must go and now
also you're saying it's bad yeah it's
because you didn't like trump you didn't
want to be a part of that so you joined
the democrats that's it now now your id
your ideology was always immaterial
irrelevant you're just claiming to
support things for the sake of making
money that's it
when you have that
you have the democrats looking to young
people and saying we got to get their
vote what do we do and they say well
these people are in favor of a lot of
really weird things you know like
they're castrating kids and then
democrats are like will we get the vote
they're like yeah but you're probably
going to lose all the rest of them
they're like let's go for it
now you have loudoun county parents
electing yunkan because they're like i'm
out whatever this is is nuts i don't
want to be involved in it
i think people are switching parties for
that reason and i think the narrative of
it's to sabotage
republicans is is nonsense i think some
do but i think it's a minority tiny tiny
fraction i agree with that and and you
know loudoun county i i saw some of
those school board hearings
they weren't i mean talk about nuts
i mean there was one i think it was one
guy who was entering and he got tackled
to the ground and handcuffed and and he
was made out to be some kind of you know
neo-nazi alt-right crazy purse when then
you look into the story you find out
that he was actually his daughter was uh
allegedly raped in the restroom by i
think it was proven that she was right
right maybe yeah and and that's the kind
of thing where i think parents are
looking at that and going you know what
no enough
you know you don't you the state
shouldn't or the government shouldn't
step in and tell a parent how to raise
their kid and our kids should be safe
and that's values and i think the values
of of america
um i mean you know i have conversations
with you know both sides and in the
middle and there just seems to be more
reasonable civil discourse with people
on the right yeah so we we had this
event in new york just as on saturday
it's fun
the festival of ideas put on by
minds.com
and that is the idea can we bring
together you know different factions
different people to come and talk about
these issues and the answer is no you
can't and i think the reason no you
can't is because the moral framework of
the two factions has become so at odds
with each other that
you can bring people together but they
cannot
well i should say this i think the left
can't understand the right but the right
can understand the left so i'll give you
the example of the challenge we had a
panel it was uh uh james o'keefe tulsi
gabbard ben burgess of jacobin he's a
socialist a writer i think he's a social
i don't but he writes for socials
magazine and uh uh and i we're on this
panel
before the uh before the show like
literally minutes
james confronts ben burgess about a
video edit saying that he cut out this
important piece and challenged ben on it
and ben berg's response was i don't know
he responds at the time
when we were on stage we're supposed to
be talking about media manipulation and
i think ben perfectly exemplified the
divide
james o'keefe said in this video
x happened
and you omitted it
ben said
unions are important and good and if you
don't support unions you don't support
free speech
therefore
james o'keefe exposing a union was
harmful to them and that means what he
was doing was bad and then now my
attitude was my response was that has
nothing to do with truth or journalism
you've started your argument from
from the point of an i i i from an
ideological point unions are good james
targeted unions james is bad
that's not journalism
uh the question is
is james telling the truth that was the
issue is he being deceptive or not
and the answer is no you're just mad
because he did something damaging to
your ideological cause this is a writer
for a major publication i think jacob's
fairly good they defend free speech i
can respect that but that exemplified
the problem perfectly the corporate
press the woke
like aoc said it doesn't matter if
you're factually correct it matters if
you're morally correct
that's the difference between us and
them and that's called ad hominem uh
it's a fallacy it's a diplomatic fallacy
if you attack someone's character that's
called like if you make a comment like
well you you wear green and everyone
knows that's the ugliest color which is
right
not the
character but this this is not that this
is
james o'keefe said thing happened thing
is true ben said but thing is bad for
unions and unions are good therefore you
are bad and i i'm not that that's not ad
hominem that is like or your work is bad
your journalism is deceptive and wrong
because it's harming unions which are
important for the people yeah he
attacked his work ethic
yeah no no well the point is
you're either saying
a dog jumps out a window and a
journalist will say dog jumped out a
window and an ideolog ideologue will say
the dog was thrown out the window by an
evil person
because that's the moral good to condemn
those who raised the dog in a system of
oppression that resulted in him jumping
out the window in fear yeah like no that
didn't happen someone the dog just
jumped i don't know there's a point you
made earlier i kind of want to seize on
for a moment here you mentioned that
conservatives know more about how the
left thinks than the left knows about
how the right thinks and this is a point
we've made a number of times i think
this has also been
verified by different studies where they
pulled people on the left and asked them
to describe conservative opinions ask
people on the right to do the same thing
one thing we don't talk about as much is
the fact that
left-wing people also don't understand
the way that people who they consider to
be their allies think they don't
understand the way the people who they
claim to represent think they literally
do not take the time to figure out what
anyone else in the world believes they
think they have all the world's problems
solved with their ideology so whenever
it comes to
women
or the black community or
any other group that you know the
islamic community for whom they claim to
advocate
they're constantly pushing for ideas
that members of that group generally
don't like so i've said this before
on the blm website there was language
about abolishing the nuclear family
right and when you look at blm and when
you look at how
black and brown have been included on
the pride flag to include black lives
matter well when it comes to the
question of homosexuality according to
polling data the black community is more
conservative than the white community
right what about women well
they seem to think that for women
liberation means you know going into the
workplace having an only fans
stripping selling new pictures of
yourself this is not how most women
think and then when it comes to islam
they want to be able to lump islam into
a category with these other groups as if
islamic religious fundamentalists have
the same goals or interests as these
other groups my point is
they make
zero effort to understand what anyone
else wants or what anyone else thinks
it's not just conservatives they're
complete solipsists there was a in the
uk i can remember the neighborhood of
the area the city there was an lgbt
curriculum in a classroom in a muslim
neighborhood so all of the religious
muslims came out protesting
and you actually had this video where
it's like a gay guy saying like i'm
doing this for you and they're like we
don't like you and we don't like what
you're doing
but these these leftists have created
this narrative where
they're the saviors of all these
different groups there was one thing
that happened where some tv show
depicted a female muslim character who
was gay yep and the muslim community
went was it not out like it was they
were an uproar like this is offensive to
us it's like did you think that going
against their strong religious
conservative muslim values
would make them like you yeah well
exactly and so i think part of the
reason they would do that is to kind of
like
groom the western muslim community into
adopting more of their values i remember
when that happened i did a cartoon
poking fun at the idea and there were
actually a number of muslim people
because it was funny the whole idea
behind the cartoon was like the left
just seeing groups of people as
caricatures and so there were some jokes
in there about like islam and what the
left's doing but the feedback i got from
muslim people is that they really liked
it even though it was poking some fun
they're like poking fun at the ideas of
the stereotypes because they're so sick
and tired of the left claiming that
they're like their avatar or pawn you
know and represent them somehow like the
muslim community is like in any way
emblematic of what the left's goals are
we talked about a little bit before the
show greg i was mentioning to you that i
think they call it the left even people
that call themselves leftists because
they want to project this idea that
they're half of the conversation when in
fact it's a very small group of
without making too many generalizations
drugged out people that are on like
adderall and other amphetamines since
they were 12 or whatever i don't know
how many of them there are but a lot of
people are on those like suicide watch
type people and
they have a microphone so
everyone else they're inside this like
echo chamber house of fun mirrors and
they see around and they see all these
other deranged people and then they
think if they can if they can somehow
help the deranged people then they're
helping the entire system but it's just
they're just like scratching their own
backs and everyone else can see inside
it's a one-way system we can all see
them doing it at least most people that
are aware of the media and the
manipulation stuff that are watching
around that stuff can tell the the
transgender like cutting up a kid's
genitals when they're nine is probably
not very good for the kid have you have
you seen all these performative outrage
videos of a roe v wade
no i haven't seen any so there's uh
women like screaming like
and they're like punching pillows and
things like that
they're all very obviously performative
for two reasons
they've set up their camera pressed
record stood back and then started
screaming
so they planned it it wasn't a true
display of emotion it was just there's
one video where you see one woman like
banging a pillow on the ground and it
starts with a brief her looking at the
camera and then going someone's moving
the camera and filming her and then she
stops and then pauses for second looking
at the camera very clearly an edited
performance
people see that and say oh if i'm to fit
in i need to be angry about this they
don't know why they're angry they were
just told to be billy joe armstrong goes
on stage and he's like i'm renouncing my
citizenship because people are so stupid
and he's probably not gonna i would be
very surprised if he literally renounced
his citizenship it's a complicated
process i doubt he's gonna go to the
consulate and be like yes here's my
signature my official form of renunciate
renunciation and i would like to have a
meeting with the uh american consulate
officer to swear my like it's not
something you just do
so i really doubt he's gonna he's gonna
go back he's gonna smoke pot and go like
what was i gonna do again
but when he goes on stage and says this
everyone's like yeah yeah i'm angry too
i don't know why but the guy on stage
said to be they see all the videos these
young women see the videos getting likes
so they make more videos like this
to get attention they don't actually
know what they're protesting they don't
even know what roe v wade did
they don't know why it was overturned so
they just say it's the handmaid's tale
get your bible out of my body and it's
like they didn't overturn us on any
religious grounds at all
well part of what part of what i think
is well and that's also because this is
another example of of the left not
knowing how anyone else thinks not
knowing how to frame an issue they think
that this is just a matter of like some
small minority of religious
fundamentalists who want to ban abortion
and that there are no reasons outside of
you know divine revelation to want to
oppose abortion but also
they think that i think some of them
really seem to think that abortion has
been criminalized nationwide because of
this this is part of what's so funny
about um armstrong billy joe armstrong
yeah saying that he's going to renounce
his citizenship
many blue states are still going to have
abortion laws which are more lenient
than the ones in europe and in the uk
particularly yeah so he's going to be
moving to a country that probably has
stricter abortion laws than the state
he's fleeing
king well as a queen yeah i know it's it
that's insane he can move to colorado
where there's zero restrictions instead
the uk the uk has like a de facto
abortion because the women can be like
my mental health is affected and they'll
give them the abortion but you still
need a process worse in colorado you
don't and he's complaining it's like
dude
the states are like like how big is the
uk you know like com com comparable to
what state oh that's a good question i
wouldn't hazard a guess but quite small
compared to uh
many of the states the united states and
all of europe are comparable in size
right so the uk
living there would be akin to him being
like i'm moving to colorado it's like a
different state it does it it's crazy
that
europe has no unified abortion law
similar to how the united states doesn't
and there's there's actually i think
finland i think it's banned outright
that could be wrong it's like heavily
restricted or something
i think most states most countries in
europe it's like 12 weeks yeah at least
and they're they're decently restricted
in the united states up until the
overturning of row the us was way more
lenient than europe
do you think it's it's similar to you
know with him just spouting this you
know
get behind this i haven't really you
know i don't have an opinion or a value
on it because anyway i'm not i'm a
birthing person uh who let's say one of
these days um you know it's like it's
like i saw during covid the new diseased
until proven healthy i call it covert
woke you know it's like
it's like cancel cultures guilty till
proven innocent it's let's just you know
let's let's chant the slogan and be part
of that crowd that is on the righteous
side without really just investigating
what well it is it is self-righteous
it's it's it's a it's a bunch of people
with pitchforks and torches yeah and
they're like i'm just here to fit in
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you